hello there reject nation I'm Tyrone
Magnus and I'm Akasaka Saad and Tyrone
Magnus the two coolest black reactors we
are going to do they're our friends
Tyrone today I've been in our sketches
[Laughter]
we're gonna talk about a movie called
chase for a couple of reasons we want to
check this movie out chase is actually
associate produced by Tyrone Magnus and
it is written directed by man named
Michael Matteo Rossi who I believe is
John's best friend my personal
competition if I'm not mistaken
yeah man you better get that best man
slot I mean he's edging you that's son
of a [ __ ] plate no you should play
Tyrone in the Tyrone biopic and get you
know ostracized from Hollywood for
making that bad decision I will I'm
getting a can I go back oh of fairways I
mean we first met on the set of a no
budget found footage movie I think that
is still called loss of life that he
wrote at the time and I think eventually
wound up co-directing if I'm not
mistaken and then we've just kept in
touch over the years and stuff like that
you know we see each other here and
there yeah what I'll say then is because
we have friends involved in this movie
this movie is perfect yeah go rent it
right away we rent it on Amazon paid $5
ourselves this onesie
changed my life this was the best movie
ever made
guys just click off the video it's
better than sex no alcohol required well
he plenty of watch time 50 million
stuckman if you haven't heard of this
movie we got permission here's the
trailer for you guys
it's my passionate when you're good at
something you keep doing it I don't want
you to go soft on me ever I don't give a
[ __ ] if this from two years ago you go
soft on me I'm gonna make sure she said
I'd do everything in my power you know
nothing [ __ ] what we don't need him
chase you were too good at what you do
to be pegged in or limited the [ __ ] is
[ __ ] with his head you see that right
she makes him happy
[ __ ] it
so yeah case it wasn't clear chase hit
man works for miles
played by Aries Spears Aries Spears is
like I want you having no family maybe
if you warm is making the warm and said
ice cold man what's cooler than being
cool ice ice cold I'll start off with
saying this some of the main takeaways I
got from this I would have to say are
the actor who plays chase get it it's a
double meaning yeah miles and miles
always on the run those two Damien
putler and Aries Spears are definitely
the highlights of this movie to me
especially when they're together
Damien Parker I don't know what else is
guys done grim from TV nope never seen
that but this characters required to be
an intense lethal weapon who has a
random offbeat sense of humor from time
to time the guy is certainly not just
like when you see him intimidating
because oh yeah he's buff and he's got a
beard and slicked back hair
his stare he's got these eyes that just
communicate death and just don't me you
know he's got that look he does have a
great hitman look he looks like he could
choke the life out of you with his eyes
and flex and finishes like we our heroes
are all fit nowadays but he was buffer
that I'm used to seeing just like a
hitman you know what I like the
attention to detail in this movie is you
see him working out a bit yeah like
quite a couple times and a lot of he's
like hitman movies or whatever they eat
like [ __ ] right he has to stay in shape
I love that actually him and Aries
Spears together like their relationship
especially in the moments where they
just get to actually hang out and my
guess is maybe improv a little bit like
those were some of the most enjoyable
and coalescent parts of the movie I
think
well Aries Spears surprised me Aries
Spears mainly not for his comedy work on
that TV and he plays like the mob boss
villain in this this movie obviously
takes inspiration from Drive and there's
this
interesting correlation I don't know if
this is intentional or just coincidence
but in drive my boss Albert Brooks
comedian and then in this movie mob boss
Aries Spears comedian the title of this
movie has a similar fun-to-drive yeah so
perhaps it was intentional but Aries
Spears really sells this role he's very
very charismatic in it but it requires
more than that there requires this level
of death where you you don't trust him
underneath this surface like you could
see how this guy can win you over with
this charm but how he's also ruthlessly
cunning and I actually really
appreciated his role but when those two
have scenes together whether it's in
person or whether they're just going
back and forth on the phone I thought
their chemistry was really believable
they're supposed to have this
relationship where they've been best
friends since they were 15 years old I
also thought the writing of the dialogue
was at its best when they were
interacting with one another because
this could have easily been oh you get
into Act two Aries Spears betrays him
you know it just becomes that it's like
really OneNote dialogue with them but
they kept the nuance of their history
within the dialog that Aries Spears
motivation is kind of ridiculous he has
his best friend who he just wants to be
an isolated cold hit man and then he
feels him having a family is gonna
weaken the job so when they fight with
each other or argue they can get
threatening or whatever however they
still argue in a way where you could
feel that best friendship it's more than
just a performance is also in the
dialogue and I like the way how Chase
will react like crazy stuff is con like
why are you doing this you know
yeah I like that attitude because that
wasn't element I wasn't expecting in
this dynamic yeah for sure and those are
the little charms that give the movie
its best little you know unique nuggets
what you think of the cinematography
Johnny the cinematography was all right
I mean it's definitely cleanly captured
and there is a lot of expressive
lighting for sure yeah I enjoyed that
aspect of it it definitely has a lot of
like pinks and blue gels and stuff like
that and you know the LA neo-noir
yeah yeah yeah one I mean this is
in indie film I I don't know what the
budget is but I 100 million dollars was
one right hi Romy Magnus's credit card I
assume it was not 100 million dollars
now so I imagine that you're kind of
dressing up a lot of what's at your
disposal and for the most part yeah I
thought it coalesced visually pretty
well anyway oh this could have been like
a lot worse you think about it before
I've seen independent movies but like
Janna on an audio-visual level
everything was very competent yeah very
comforting an arthouse action indie film
that gets released on Amazon yeah oh boy
you can find stuff for your like find
why do you why'd you even released find
a lot of that but here it seemed like
the whole cast and crew were really
giving their 100% and yeah I definitely
had to work within the limitations that
I'm sure arose from time to time yeah
there's also a supporting cast in here
that can be pretty hit or miss for me
I'm not trying to make a statement here
just the fact quickest way to sum it up
I felt that a lot of the ethnic actors
were really good most of the white
actors were not too great what did you
say
I've richer really was a pretty
well-known actor as of one of the more
memorable scenes in the movie and he's
really he's white he's white he's
experienced that's why but there's this
actor here new plays a character called
Burke this is perfect Burke was really
hit or miss pretty much a Miss for me
there's a scene where Burke is
interacting with a bunch of like Latino
characters and I thought all the Latino
actors were very believable they felt
very lived-in whereas Burke I know the
idea it's kind of make him feel like an
outsider but there was something about
his performance so I really felt like he
was just constantly trying to do it but
not being it he reminded me of just out
of a different movie or so he truly
reminded me of fun yeah Crowe and
Jessica Morris plays Blair and I felt
like she had some pretty good scenes
than some scenes were missed but I also
think a lot of that will come down to
the writing of this movie there were
definitely issues I had with some of the
writing and some of the directing the
writing
especially in the first half felt very
repetitive I felt like it was really
hitting me on the head with back story
but not even really diving deeper and
deeper into backstory but kind of just
repeating the history and repeating the
character problems at hand yeah you know
like miles is tough
oh you're supposed to be ice cold you
have a family now chase family though
yes he's getting in the way it's like
the same kind of dialogue throughout and
so I felt like there was a lot being
told about them and less being lived in
through them this movie takes a lot of
inspiration from the movie Drive it's
very apparent and the thing would drive
I notice I want to compare it is because
the inspiration is obviously their drive
is a very not a funny yeah drive is a
rather you know quiet movie you know
there are characters who talk a lot but
for the most part it's not heavily
reliant on dialogue there's no narration
I mean Ryan Gosling is like 10 lines in
the movie that's the main character this
movie I felt kind of abused its dialogue
a little too much especially the f-word
that's a point very early on run like I
get that this is a crime movie crime
action movie there's usually swearing in
here at times it felt like he was trying
to replicate or emulate the likes of
Tarantino well I just reject your
hypotheses instead of just doing his own
thing and making something unique
because this does pretty much fall under
a rather cliche predictable plot can it
be fun yeah but I also feel like they
could have gone deeper with the way
characters especially are reacting to
certain situations and reacting to
things when the action begins with this
whole invasion with Chase the families
attacked the son is kidnapped and then
Blair is in the hospital it doesn't seem
like conflicted at all about the
situation other than don't kill them and
get her yeah yeah there are certain
flips that happen because it's a movie
and then on physical levels like one
point Burke is first scene he gets like
stabbed in his hand versus like aah but
then a minute later I had to go would ya
seem like he's affected at all by the
fact that he was stabbed yeah yeah
that's a script soup
yeah you know so many crime movies and
films like this have similar story
elements when it comes to the writing
that was an area that I think could use
the most polish especially going into
your next project or whatever not that
you need my opinion but um the thing is
this movie has a juxtaposition for me
because there is an internal narration
and then there is the rest of the
dialogue and to me the internal
narration was the most interesting piece
of writing in this movie because while I
didn't always love that there was a
narration at certain times it was the
most personal the dialogue got and I
thought it was the most expressive the
word choices were so I thought you know
on that front pretty good job with the
narration I would have liked to have
seen some of that character go into the
actual dialogue and the actual scenes
between characters though because I
think if you trust your plot elements
enough and let your characters talk
about how they're seeing the situation
rather than just what the situation is
that'll really bring the scenes further
to life and that will help set you apart
from the things that are similar to a
lot of other crime movies because again
it's a genre rife with homage and
borrowing and you know tropes and stuff
like that so yeah a little more focus on
the character aspects of the writing in
those nuances and you know going even
further with the cameras and making it
more expressive in terms of angles and
editing to compliment the expressive
lighting which I really liked
yeah stuff like that because at times
the way it was shot was cool and then
there were other times where I could
feel what he was going for but not
really understanding the deeper
emotional nuance to that's why that
director like Scorsese would do that
editing bit or this kind of shot at er
times where the shots felt a little bit
more forced and less natural and in the
moment they were trying to go for cool
yeah I said I'm understanding the deeper
nuances behind the shot yeah let's les
to complement the scene overall yeah but
as it stands it's an arthouse in the
action thriller and in that department
it pretty much succeeds because working
within limitations like this you could
still feel there's a lot of care put
into this movie as by no means
a lazy film every actors fully committed
you feel everyone on the crew is fully
committed as a lot of locations a lot of
scenes it's very competently put
together it's just yeah I could have
used some fine-tuning here or there
maybe another rewrite or whatever but as
it stands it's an enjoyable action
thriller and highly recommend you guys
go check it out read sit on Amazon like
we did this wasn't some hookup we paid
to watch this in Sookie dollars 5/5
roundup that dollar ninety-nine dart a
petition we need Aries Spears in more
movies playing villains yes that time to
good news alright guys well did you see
chase
subscribe